[موسيقى]
عقود مرت على استقرار بني حنيفه في حجر
اليمامه زارهم جد الاعشى اتيا من الحجاز
بعدما ذاع صيتهم في انحاء الجزيره العربيه
جد الاعشى طلب من ابن ثعلبه ان يسكن
بجواره في حجر اليمامه لكن الاخيره رفض
طلبه ونفحه منطقه قريبه من حجر سميت بعد
ذلك بمنفوحه
لماذا سميت منفوحه منفوحه
هناك عدد من الروايات لكن نتفق على
الروايه التاريخيه عندما اتى جد الاعشى
سعد بن ضبيعه عندما اتجد لجد بني حنيفه
عبيد بن ثعلبه فقال له عشركنا معك في
الرياض في حجر اليمامه فالتفت سعد بن عبيد
التفت الى الجهه الجنوبيه
واخبر سعد بن ربيعه قال
سانفحكم هذه التفت الى الجنوب النفح معناه
الاعطاء اعطاء شيء ونفحه
شاقتك من قتلته
فالوتر فالحاجري الى مارد فقعوا منفوحه في
الحائري هناك عدد كبير قلنا من المعالم
وايضا الاماكن التي يذكرها الاعشى في شعره
داخل ايضا الرياض وداخل حجر اليمامه وداخل
منفوحه والمحيط ايضا هناك حتى نمار اشار
له الاعشى ايضا في اشعار قانون مار فبطن
الخارج ادهما وهناك ايضا اشعار مختلفه
يشير لها الاعشى في شعره لكنها اصبحت ايضا
ناقلها او ذكرها المؤرخون البلدانيون
ليؤكدون ايضا على ان هذه الاسماء كبيره
ومتعدده في هذا الوادي على البلدات
التاريخيه الواقعه في منفوحه وحجر اليمامه
وغيرها اذا بطن الخال اللي هو نعم ونمار
ما زال اسمه نمر